[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: So first of all,
thank you all for being here.
My name is Jason Silva.
I'm the host of the
TV show "Brain Games"
on the National
Geographic Channel.
I'm also the creator
of "Shots of Awe"
in partnership with
Discovery Digital Networks.
And I'm really honored to
be here today with you guys
and with my very dear
friend Steven Kotler, who
is a "New York Times"
best-selling author,
brilliant thinker, co-founder
of the Flow Genome Project,
and just one of my favorite
people in the world.
And we've been having
these mind jams every time
we hang out here in New York.
We've never recorded it.
So we thought, why don't
we get together and put
this on camera, and
invite a bunch of people,
and let's talk about creativity,
innovation, flow states,
and all that good stuff.
So Steven, what's up?
STEVEN KOTLER: Hey, Jason.
I don't know how
I top that intro.
JASON SILVA: Well,
that was just to set up
a little bit of context.
But to really get
things started,
I'm going to ask you
to define flow states.
This is your specialty.
So for those that are not
familiar with the concept,
even though we keep hearing
about it in the press,
we keep hearing about it in
the media-- welcome, welcome.
Have a seat.
Yes.
But flow states are associated
with peak human performance,
right?
It's when we seemingly
achieve the impossible.
So tell us, what
are flow states?
STEVEN KOTLER: So
you may know flow
by a lot of other
synonyms-- runner's high,
being in the zone.
If you're a basketball player,
you call it being unconscious.
If you were a beatnik
jazz musician,
you called it being
in the pocket.
If you're a stand-up comic,
you call it the forever box.
Flow is sort of
a technical term.
And it is technically
defined as an optimal state
of consciousness, a
state of consciousness
where we perform our best
and we feel our best.
It refers to those moments
of rapt attention and total
absorption, where we get so
focused on the task at hand
that everything else disappears.
So your sense of self, your
sense of self-consciousness,
they vanish completely.
Time dilates, which is
a fancy way of saying it
passes strangely.
So sometimes it speeds
up, and five hours
will go by in five minutes.
And occasionally it
slows down, and you'll
get that freeze-frame
effect-- maybe any of you
have been in a car crash
or seen "The Matrix."
And throughout, all
aspects of performance--
that's mental and physical--
go through the roof.
And if you want a quick
and dirty definition of it,
flow is as close to
picture-perfect decision
making as we can
possibly get, which is
where the state gets its name.
In the state of
flow, every decision,
every action leads seamlessly,
fluidly, perfectly,
to the next.
Flow feels flowy.
So it's actually
a technical term.
It came out of, actually,
one of the largest
psychological studies ever done.
And when they were interviewing
people, about it they
kept using this term, flow.
So that's where it came from.
JASON SILVA: So I'm
obsessed with flow states.
I've experienced them regularly.
But since I was a
little kid, when
I got into this wonderfully
inspired headspace--
everything seemed effortless--
but creating a flow state,
eliciting a flow state,
catalyzing a flow state,
has always been
kind of enigmatic.
It's like peak experience,
this haphazard phenomenon that
sometimes emerges and
sometimes it doesn't.
But as a control freak, I've
always wanted to understand,
what are the precursors for
triggering these ecstatic
moments, these
highly lucid moments.
And for me it's
always been, when
it comes to writing, when
it comes to speaking, when
it comes to, as you say, lateral
thinking, free association,
connecting the
dots in a new way.
And you guys-- you and Jamie
Wheal, part of the Flow Genome
Project-- have started to
really peek beneath the lid,
so to speak, and figure out
what's going on in the brain
when we go into
these flow states.
Now, you guys are
saying, what I remember
reading is the advances in
psychology, neurobiology,
psychopharmacology, and
technology, all these four
pillars are advancing so fast,
that now all of a sudden,
we get to see what's going on.
We get to stop speaking
in woo-woo terms,
and be like, what's happening,
and how can we reproduce this,
and how can we benefit from it.
So tell me about these
advances and what you guys are
doing with Flow Genome Project.
STEVEN KOTLER: Yeah.
We can actually,
believe it or not,
thank George Bush Sr. for this.
1990, declared it the
Decade of the Brain.
And money flooded
into neuroscience.
And most it was spent on
neuroimaging technology.
So we got really, really good
at peering inside the brain
and figuring out
what's going on.
So for the very first
time in history,
we actually are now starting
to decode what happens in flow.
And I'll just give you a
little bit of the neuroscience,
just so you have some context.
Two main things are important.
From a neuroanatomical level,
normally the old idea of what
happened about ultimate
performance--and I'm sure
you're all familiar with
it-- the 10% brain myth,
the idea that we're only
using 10% of our brain.
So ultimate
performance, aka flow,
must be the full
brain on overdrive.
Turns out we had it
exactly backwards.
In flow, parts of the brain
are not becoming hyperactive.
They're actually deactivating.
They're shutting down.
The technical term for this is
transient-- meaning temporary--
hypo, H-Y-P-O, it's
the opposite of hyper,
it means to slow down, to
shut down, to deactivate--
frontality, which refers
to the prefrontal cortex,
the part of your brain
that's right back here.
Prefrontal cortex is
your executive function.
It's all of your higher
cognitive functions.
It's the part that you
most associate with you,
so your sense of morality,
your sense of will,
your sense of self,
complex decision making.
In flow, that portion
of the brain shuts down.
So why does time pass
so strangely in flow?
Because time, it turns
out, is calculated
all over the prefrontal cortex.
And as parts of it
start to wink out,
we can no longer separate past,
from present, from future.
We're plunged into what's
called the deep now.
Another thing that happens
in the prefrontal cortex--
and this is probably
the best part--
is when the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex-- and there's
going to be a quiz later.
So I hope you're
all taking notes.
When this portion of
your brain shuts down,
it does a lot of things.
But one of the most
important things it does,
is it's your inner critic.
So that nagging,
always-on, defeatist voice
that's in your head
that doesn't shut up,
that won't leave you
alone, shuts up in flow.
So we experience this
profound liberation.
We are literally free of
ourselves for the first time.
As a result, creativity
goes up, risk-taking
goes up, et cetera, et cetera.
There's also a
combination of five
of the most potent
neurochemicals
the brain can produce.
These are all
performance-enhancing
chemicals.
But they serve a
second function,
which is they're all
feel-good, pleasure drugs.
And just to give
you an idea, one
of the chemicals
that shows up in flow
is dopamine, which you guys
have probably heard of.
Dopamine-- well, let's back up.
Cocaine is widely considered the
most addictive drug on Earth.
All that happens when somebody
uses cocaine, is the brain--
JASON SILVA: They get dopamine.
STEVEN KOTLER:
They get dopamine.
So you get dopamine.
You get endorphins.
And just endorphins are
opiates, natural version
of heroin or morphine,
just the one our brain
produces as painkillers.
But the most common
endorphin in the brain
is 100 times more powerful
than medical morphine.
The combination--
so first of all,
if you wanted to go out
onto the street and cocktail
the street drug
versions of this state,
you'd end up dead or in a coma.
Would not work.
Some of the drugs would
actually cancel themselves out.
Your brain does it perfectly.
Which means flow is the most
addictive state on Earth.
We will go extraordinarily
far out of our way
to get more of it-- as
Jason, I'm sure, will attest.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
Well, one of the
things that's blown
my mind about the attention
that flow has gotten recently
in the media is that
it's given it a language.
It's given us an ability to
describe the ineffable ecstasy
of being in that zone,
being in that pocket--
whether it's the jazz musician
when he is improvising
and he literally transcends
himself, the basketball player
achieving the impossible,
the snowboarder,
the elite athletes pushing
beyond the limits of the sport.
Something is happening
in this moment.
And I remember there was
some science recently
where they scanned
the brains of rappers.
And they had them
freestyle lyrics, which
means completely improvised.
And then, of course, they had
them recite memorized lyrics.
And what they said
is exactly that.
The lateral prefrontal
cortex, the inner critic,
the self-editing, goes away.
Or as your partner, Jamie Wheal,
says, your inner Woody Allen.
That self-crippling self-doubt,
that self-consciousness,
that so often acts
as paralysis for us--
to be free from that
is such ecstasy.
And so what I'm curious about
is how do you take this and make
this mainstream?
Because yes, it is all about
us getting high and entering
these flow states.
But then what do we do
with these flow states,
when we say we achieve
the impossible?
You give a lot lectures,
corporate talks
all over the world because
apparently people doing
business are 10 times
more productive when
they achieve flow.
So it's like, can you grab this
high that artists are using,
that athletes are using, and
bring it into the workplace,
and bring it into
these new spaces
so that we can essentially
upgrade society.
I mean, this is
an ambitious idea,
but this is what you guys are
doing at Flow Genome, right?
STEVEN KOTLER: It is
kind of what we're doing.
And they're not 10 times-- so
McKinsey did a 10-year study.
And they found top
executives in flow
are five times more productive.
So it's 500% more productive.
It means you could
go to work on Monday,
spend Monday in a flow
state, take Tuesday
through Friday off,
and get as much done
as your steady-state peers.
That's how much of an
amplification in performance
you're actually talking about.
What we now know is--
and it's interesting.
So for a really long
time, studying flow
was problematic because
how do you know if somebody
was in a flow state?
You had to give them a
subjective questionnaire.
And it's flimsy science.
And it's extremely
well-validated questionnaire.
There's about 50 years'
worth of research.
But what started happening
in the past 25 years
is, for reasons I'll get to in
a second, action adventure sport
athletes-- snowboarders,
skiers, surfers,
whatnot-- they got
better at reliably
and repeatedly reproducing
the state of flow than anybody
else pretty much in the
history of the world.
As a result, we've seen
near-exponential growth
in ultimate human performance
in action adventure sports.
So incredible things have
happened in the past 25 years.
More impossible feats had
been done than ever before.
From a research
perspective, they gave us
something we've never
had before, which
is at the upper
level of competition,
these men and women
are performing at--
if they're not in flow, they're
going home in a body bag.
Or they're going
to the hospital.
So suddenly, our
research subjects,
if they lived through
the experience,
we knew they were in flow.
And having this as a backdrop,
a data set to work with,
has allowed us to
work backwards.
We now know there are 17
triggers, 17 pre-conditions
that lead to more flow.
And we also know there's
something called the flow
cycle, a four-stage process
the state moves through,
which is sort of the
map of the territory.
You combine these things,
like we do at the Flow Genome
Project-- and this
isn't, I mean there's
lots of different
people out there
teaching flow and whatnot.
But I'll just give
you our numbers.
We've taught-- I don't
even know how many people--
thousands of people
at this point.
On average, when people
come through our courses--
six-week course, by the
way, not even a hard course.
The homework's a little strange.
But it's a six-week course.
People are reporting a fivefold,
so a 500%, increase in flow,
a 500% increase in creativity,
and a 300% increase
in self-confidence.
And the last one, by the
way, self-confidence--
we had no idea that it
was going to happen.
It was just something that
emerged out of the data.
We were really shocked by it.
But yes, the state is
entirely trainable.
And as we get better
at our neuroscience,
it's going to get more
and more trainable.
JASON SILVA: So eventually
we'll get to the point
that we can literally be
able to press a button
and get into our highest
state, so to speak.
STEVEN KOTLER: You
can do it already.
I mean, so one of the ways
they induce flow artificially
now is transcranial
magnetic stimulation.
They literally shoot a
big neuromagnetic pulse
through the brain.
They knock out the
prefrontal cortex,
inducing artificial flow,
kicking people into flow.
DARPA did this.
They took a group of snipers
and they trained them up in flow
by knocking out the
prefrontal cortex.
They found they learned 200%
to 500% faster than normal.
They redid the study with
novice, nonmilitary archers,
riflemen, and pistol shooters--
three different categories.
They found the time it takes
to go from novice to expert
can be cut in half by flow.
So yes, there is
already a button for it.
JASON SILVA: Which is wonderful.
So besides it
being a wonderfully
smart and productive technique
to assimilate and to learn,
there's also its
connection fundamentally
to the human condition.
Jamie Wheal had a
wonderful TEDx Talk
called-- your partner--
from "Altered States
to Altered Traits" and this
idea of hacking the flow state.
He said most of us, while we
recognize these flow states,
we get hooked on the state
instead of raising the stage.
So we go there.
But then when we come back into
ourselves Monday morning again
and it's like, what
the fuck, right?
STEVEN KOTLER: Right.
JASON SILVA: And part of the
thing that he was talking about
is that if you think
of our self systems,
the way that our
homeostasis right now,
we're like a colander.
And we're full of holes.
And no matter how much flow
we pour in, we're draining.
So you have to be
constantly pouring it in
to achieve any kind
of equilibrium.
But then he talks about the
idea of turning our colander
into a chalice so that we could
literally make flow the default
condition.
Now, technology is
advancing exponentially.
We have new construction
kits for our reality.
You explore this in abundance
in "Bold" and your new book
"Tomorrowland."
Can you speculate about how
we might raise the stage,
reverse-engineer ourselves,
creating a default flow state?
STEVEN KOTLER: It's an
interesting question.
One thing for sure, there's no
such thing as a permanent flow
state.
JASON SILVA: Bummer.
STEVEN KOTLER:
The neurochemicals
that produce flow
are in short supply.
So once you burn
through them, and you
can burn through some
of them in 20-- dopamine
and norepinephrine will
burn out of your brain
in about 20 minutes.
Takes a little while
to replenish them.
So there's no--
occasionally people
will come up to me like, I
live in a permanent flow state.
And I'm like, yeah.
We have a word for that.
We call it schizophrenia.
JASON SILVA: Right.
STEVEN KOTLER: So you don't
get to live in a permanent flow
state.
You can cycle through it.
And you can shorten the
distance between cycles very,
very quickly.
So you can move through it.
There's a lot ninjutsu to there.
But I mean, what does
it mean for society
if the 500% more productivity,
if you just-- I'm
going to throw out
some other numbers.
And they seem
really, really wonky.
And we don't have
enough time to go
into them because they're huge.
Creativity in flow,
500% to 700% amplified.
Motivation goes up
a similar level.
Learning goes up
So think about what this
means for education.
There's studies done on college.
If we can get kids through
college in three years,
the savings and
the amount of money
that comes into the
economy is significant.
How do you accelerate
learning that way?
We know how.
Flow will already do it.
We know that flow massively
increases the immune system.
It boosts the immune system
and resets the nervous system.
Herb Benson at
Harvard has said he
thinks that flow is
responsible for most
cases of so-called
spontaneous healing.
He thinks it's actually the
neurobiology of flow that's
underneath it.
That may be overstepping the
case, as far as I'm concerned.
But it's still intriguing
and worth pursuing.
So health care, education,
technology, on, and on, and on.
What it does is it puts
society into hyperdrive,
or at least I think it does.
JASON SILVA: I love this.
So I want to connect this back
to the idea of technology,
because you write a
lot about technology.
And we've bonded around our
shared love of new construction
kits for our reality.
But OK, so we live
during disruptive times.
We live during
exponential times.
Everything is changing.
Nobody really understands
why until they
understand exponential change.
Ray Kurzweil from Google
explains, we think linearly.
Our brains evolved in a
linear and local world.
But we live in a world
now that is exponential.
And the best example is 30
linear steps gets you to 30;
30 exponential steps
gets you to a billion.
Now, what does this mean?
It means that the smartphone
in your pocket today
is a million times cheaper,
a million times smaller,
a thousand times more
powerful than what
used to be a $60 million
supercomputer that
was half a building
in size 40 years ago.
It means a young kid in
the savannas of Africa
with a smartphone has
better communications
technology than the US
president had 25 years ago.
So new tools for new
realities, new possibilities.
Now, you co-wrote
"Abundance," bestselling book
with Peter Diamandis.
You just released "Bold."
And now you're releasing
"Tomorrowland," where science
fiction becomes science fact.
So talk to me.
Muse with me a little bit about
this idea of these new brain
scaffoldings that
we're creating and how
they're ushering
in new possibility
spaces for ourselves.
And then tell me if
you think there's
a connection between whether we
can leverage these flow states,
if these new tools
require new minds in order
to build the future
we want to build.
STEVEN KOTLER: It's interesting.
The thing that's
interesting to me
about, and that I focus
on in "Tomorrowland,"
is the next step out.
Yes, we all know
that science fiction
is becoming science fact.
And that's everywhere.
The random fact of the week--
50% of your body can now be
replaced by bionics--
JASON SILVA: Amazing.
STEVEN KOTLER: which is insane.
What's really interesting
to me about all this stuff
is, for example, bionics.
Not only do we have bionic
limbs for replacement parts
and things like that for
paraplegics and quadriplegics.
But we're starting to
get exoskeletons, so
strap-on braces.
There are now ankle braces
and knee braces, bionic ankle
braces and knee braces
for the elderly.
And they put energy
back into the system.
Our brain evolved in such
a way that getting old
was something that happened.
There was nothing we
could do about it.
And the number one
complaint about getting old
is a loss of mobility.
So we now have technology that
is taking that away here today.
And it's only getting better,
because as Jason pointed out,
these are all on
exponential growth curves.
So what's interesting to
me about the transformation
of science fiction
to science fact
is less about the
whiz-bang technologies,
and more about the
fact that we're
starting to fuck with really
deep evolutionarily adaptive
systems.
We're starting to
really poke into what
it means to be human at
a really, really, really
deep level.
And it's going to start
getting interesting.
Because a lot of
the things-- it's
not even our belief systems.
It's the things that our
belief systems are built on.
JASON SILVA: It's the substrate.
STEVEN KOTLER: Exactly.
That's exactly true.
JASON SILVA: It's a great line
about Edward O. Wilson, where
he says, we have decommissioned
natural selection.
And now we must look
deep within ourselves
to decide what we
wish to become.
I mean, we've already
changed the physical,
the external, world.
If you look at a
city, what is that?
Congealed intent, as
McKenna would say,
congealed imagination.
If you look at the
topography of Manhattan,
that's shaped more by
mind, and agency, and will,
and technology than
it is by geology.
So the mind has already
trumped matter in so many ways.
But it's like, now we're
experiencing a recursion,
because now we're folding the
mind in on itself to start
to play with biology itself.
So biotechnology, mastering
the information processes
of biology,
rewriting our genome.
Having invented the gods,
we can turn into them.
STEVEN KOTLER:
And the one-- I'll
give you one example if we
want to talk about really
crazy technology, mind
uploading, the idea that we
can store ourselves
in silicon, upload
our brains into computers.
And it sounds absolutely crazy,
sounds like make-believe.
People are working on it today.
And it's actually a
multi-part system.
And a couple of the parts,
like the playback mechanism,
we have already.
The VR devices that are at
Facebook, the next generation
of Oculus can play it back.
We've already got
things that we can
plant in the brain that
can record basically all
the inputs of all your senses.
So nobody quite knows what
it is that constructs a life.
But pretty soon, if we go
by Ray Kurzweil's numbers--
and maybe you can, and maybe
you can't-- but his numbers,
by 2045, we'll be able to
simulate a brain inside
a computer.
Which means we'll be able to
store ourselves in a computer.
So the interesting
question to me
is, think about
how much blood has
been spilled in the past hundred
years in the name of religion.
Think about how
much religion uses
the threat of the hereafter
to steer morality and shape
behavior.
But what happens to
theological morality
in the face of
technological immortality?
And it sounds like
a crazy question,
but it's a question we're
going to actually have
to deal with this century.
JASON SILVA: I
mean, it's no joke.
I mean, Larry Page
from Google is
funding Calico, the California
life extension company.
Craig Venter created the
first artificial life form.
And when they asked
him, are you worried
about playing God, he
said, who's playing?
I mean, there are
legitimately brilliant,
smart, accomplished people
invested in this stuff.
And the fact-- I
mean, what is it?
It was Freeman Dyson that
says in the very near future,
a new generation of artists will
write genomes with the fluency
that Blake and
Byron wrote verses.
So if you think of technology as
a conduit to new possibilities,
new modes of human expression,
new modes of human agency-- so
the technology of
the oil painting
allowed van Gogh to emerge.
The technology of the
musical instrument
allowed Beethoven's genius.
What are we going to
make with biology?
What are our artists
going to "imagineer"
with the canvas of life?
STEVEN KOTLER: And it
sounds crazy, by the way.
What he's saying sounds crazy.
But synthetic biology--
which essentially
treats genetic code
like computer code-- it
allows us to write
life from scratch.
Right now, it's new fuels,
new foods, new medicines.
But a guy named
Andrew Hessel-- who's
a friend of ours,
who's at Autodesk,
he's a distinguished
researcher at Autodesk--
is literally building
a DNA typewriter,
meaning it's a
user-friendly interface
for synthetic biology.
So if you imagine what
happened to the web,
the web had been
around for 20 years.
Nobody but computer
scientists and the military
are using it, because
there was no way to get on.
You had to be a
computer scientist
if you wanted to play.
Marc Andreessen
comes along in 1993.
He creates Mosaic,
which becomes Netscape.
And we have 26 websites online
in 1993, 10,000 the next year,
and a million the year after.
Andrew's creating
a DNA typewriter,
which is a
user-friendly interface
for synthetic biology.
So this idea that artists are
going to be programming life
and creating in life is probably
five to 10 years away, longest.
This is, it's here now.
And I have no idea
what comes next.
What I do think-- and
I've said this before.
It's always been, especially
with these [? edge ?]
technologies, there's
always subculture
that drives it forward.
And there's this-- I call
it the rebel instinct.
Each generation seems to
outdo the next generation.
So we did weird hair.
And then we did weird clothes.
And then we did body piercings
and some low-grade tattoos.
And then we started
doing body modifications.
And now we're doing
biohacking, the cutting edge.
People are inserting
technology into their body.
So I think what
we're going to see
is the punk rockers of the
future with cat eyes, and cat
tails, and angel--
there's already a guy.
"Harper's" did that
story about the guy
who's trying to build angel
wings that are surgically
implanted.
This is what's coming.
So I do think it's
going to be a punk rock
ethos that drives this forward.
JASON SILVA: Now I want to ask
you about this idea of-- see,
I think this stuff
is astonishing.
I think if you pay attention
to what's happening-- well,
if you pay attention to
anything-- as Darwin used
to say, "Attention,
if sudden and close,
graduates into surprise;
and this into astonishment;
and this into
stupefied amazement."
And yet most of us don't
pay attention to this stuff.
Most of us go through our day,
kind of busy, kind of bored,
kind of waiting for the next
hit of some kind of ecstasy.
But I mean, we don't lose sleep
over these transformations.
We are not in a permanent
state of astonishment.
Can you tell me about
the brain chemistry
of why we are walking around
half asleep most of the time,
instead of marveling at
these new possibilities that
are emerging, that are
going to fundamentally
be changing humanity?
Why isn't this on the front
page of everything, every day?
I mean, I know you write
about this for "Forbes."
I know you're seeing
more and more of it.
But it's not everywhere
the way it should be.
I mean, why isn't everybody
talking about this
all the time?
STEVEN KOTLER: That's
a real question?
JASON SILVA: Honestly.
Yes.
STEVEN KOTLER: Well, I
don't know, actually.
I wonder that myself.
JASON SILVA: But don't you
think that there is an urgency
here, the self determination
of the species being at stake.
We should be setting
up playgrounds
for new evolutionary paradigms
to be experimented with.
STEVEN KOTLER: If you
want a biological answer,
it's the amygdala, which
is the part of your brain
that generates fear.
And so consciousness
explained very, very simply,
the brain takes in a
whole lot of information.
And there's a bunch of filters.
And the filters are
in front of what
is pattern recognition
and future prediction.
That's all that's going on
at a really deep level--
information coming
in, grabbed by
the senses, bunch of filters.
And then we're
looking for patterns.
making predictions
into the future based
on those patterns.
That's essentially what your
brain is doing at all times.
The first filter everything
hits is your amygdala.
It's where all information goes.
Why?
Because the amygdala
governs fight or flight,
safety and security.
So fear--
JASON SILVA: Gets our attention.
STEVEN KOTLER: It gets--
but it's the first filter
anybody puts up.
It's the very first thing
anything that scares you,
and all our cognitive biases
exist to narrow reality.
If you look at what the
cognitive biases do,
they're information
processing shortcuts.
All biases are like processing
shortcuts gone wrong,
because we take in
so much information.
They've done
calculations, on average--
and if you go by
the old numbers,
it's 11 million bits of
information a second.
If you go by the
new numbers, it's
400 billion bits of
information a second.
Whatever the case--
JASON SILVA: It's
what's coming in.
STEVEN KOTLER: --the
brain-- what's coming in.
The brain is
massively overwhelmed.
Your working memory can hold
about 40 bits of information
at once.
That's all you can
hold in your head,
and you've got 400
billion bits coming in.
So almost everything that
we think of as reality
is not reality, obviously.
It just gets thrown out.
And the first thing
that's throwing it out
is anything you're scared of.
So why is this not
on the front page?
Because all this stuff is scary.
It can go horribly wrong.
We were talking about what's
great with synthetic biology
and what artists are
going to produce.
I wrote an article
for "The Atlantic"
not too long ago about
customizable bioweapons that
can target individual people--
meaning I could now assassinate
the president using
synthetic biology,
and he's going to
think he got a cold.
And it's only targeting
the president.
And it's doable today.
So this stuff gets scary fast.
JASON SILVA: But see, that
does get very scary fast.
But when the answer-- yes.
But the answer that
I found Kurzweil
has given, that I
found very compelling,
is he said, well, that's
always been the case.
Technology has always
been a double-edged sword.
Fire can cook our foods
or burn our enemies.
Perhaps the most powerful
information technology
that's ever been
created is the alphabet.
And the alphabet can
be used to compose
beautiful Shakespearean sonnets
that expand our interior world.
But the alphabet
can also be used
to move people to kill each
other, and kill the other,
and so on and so forth.
So it's like, these
tools extend our will.
But they can extend our
will in any direction.
So yes, it's up to
us to make sure we
use these things wisely.
But that's always been the case.
And we haven't destroyed
ourselves thus far.
So I think we have a
pretty good track record.
Also, if you look at the
work of Steven Pinker,
he says the world
has been getting
less violent for the
last couple decades.
The world is less violent
now than it's ever been,
contrary to the doom and gloom
things we see in the media.
So do you think
that there's hope
that, in spite of these new
tools being more dangerous,
we somehow will
have the conscience
to not destroy ourselves?
STEVEN KOTLER: I don't
know if we're not
going to destroy ourselves.
I will-- to pull it back to
flow states, one of the things
that we know about
flow-- and a lot of this
has to do with all
the neurochemicals
that show up in flow.
Besides all the
performance enhancement
and their addictive
nature, they're
all social bonding chemicals.
So if flow is one of
these technologies that's
going to drive us
into the future--
all of the social
bonding chemicals, all
the norepinephrine and
dopamine which show up in flow,
that's romantic love.
Endorphins, that's
maternal love.
Anandamide is that same kind
of psychoactive chemical
that's in marijuana, makes
you open to new ideas,
and love your friends.
JASON SILVA: We love that.
STEVEN KOTLER: So these are
really potent social bonding
chemicals.
The point is that
flow expands empathy.
And a lot of these
new technologies
seem to be able play with that.
We can expand empathy.
You were talking
about the difference
between states and stages.
JASON SILVA: Absolutely.
I mean, when you start
talking about empathy,
I get excited, because there's
a great line from "Interstellar"
that talked about how
empathy rarely extends
beyond our line of sight.
And one of the things that
our new technologies do
is extend our line of sight.
I mean, if you think
virtual reality,
that potentially is
an engine of empathy.
You put somebody inside
of a virtual space,
place them in a Syrian refugee
camp, you extend their empathy.
A lot more difficult to ignore.
So you think the combination
of these external technology,
and potentially
these flow states
and this internal
technologies could
allow us to create a
more empathetic species--
could actually create
a shift that scales?
STEVEN KOTLER: Look at
the-- you've got to--
I disagree with the
"Interstellar" line,
for example.
Because what religion
is, basically,
is a way to extend empathy
beyond clan and kin.
That's what it was.
You go back 500 years.
If I wasn't related to you, if
you didn't live in my village,
you were other.
And I wanted to fight
you and kill you.
Religion allowed
us to extend that.
Suddenly, oh, wow.
He's a Christian?
I'm a Christian.
OK, we don't have
to kill each other.
So we've seen what
these-- we've also
seen them backfire, of course.
But we've seen technology,
language, massively
extend empathy before.
This is a much more
visceral version of it.
I mean, I don't think
it's everybody on ecstasy.
But it definitely opens you up.
And you're closer to it.
So I think there's
a lot of hope.
But I also think the thing
about exponential technology
at this point is it does
put the power of God
into the hands of individuals.
And that's what's
different today.
JASON SILVA: Promethean--
stealing fire from the gods.
Well, tease the name
of your next book.
STEVEN KOTLER: "Stealing Fire."
JASON SILVA: OK.
So it was originally-- we
had a whole conversation
about this idea of
mapping the highest
possible states of
human consciousness,
mapping our ecstasies,
creating a kind of cartography
of ecstatic states.
And so can you talk a little
bit about "Stealing Fire,"
flow states, and how these
emerging technologies are
allowing us to basically get
higher than we've ever gotten;
to explore new
spaces of ecstatic
rapture; the neurobiology
of mystical experience;
and so on and so forth.
Hacking nirvana.
Beyond flow.
STEVEN KOTLER: Well, so
the idea that-- Jason's
talking about a book
that I'm writing now
with my partner on the Flow
Genome Project, Jamie Wheal.
And it's called "Stealing Fire."
And the core idea is
there's a whole swatch
of experiences-- psychedelic
experiences, drug experiences,
flow states, so-called mystical
experiences, et cetera, et
cetera.
And when you start adding them
together and looking at them,
first of all what
you find is, from
a neurobiological perspective,
very, very, very similar.
For example, meditative
states and flow.
In flow, the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex goes off.
We talked about that.
But another portion
your brain, called
the medial orbital
prefrontal cortex--
which is creative
self-expression-- goes crazy,
becomes really hyperactive.
Because flow, creativity,
goes through the roof,
this portion of the brain
gets really hyperactive.
In meditative
states, because you
don't need creative
decision making,
that portion of the
brain shuts off.
Other things turn up.
When you look at
it, it's basically
a set of knobs and levers.
We're turning down
certain things.
We're turning up certain things.
We're turning on certain
things, turning off.
But it's a set category.
And what we're discovering,
really in the past 100 years,
and much more in
the past 25 years,
is there's-- I call it an upper
possibility space of human
experience that has almost
been completely off the map.
And by upper, I mean
north of happiness.
Things start at happiness,
and they get weird.
JASON SILVA: Right.
STEVEN KOTLER: But there's
a whole huge space up there
that we haven't inhabited.
And when people tripped into
it, we thought they were crazy.
We burned them at
stakes for a long time,
or we called them drug addicts.
And we wrote them off and
banished them, whatever.
All this stuff is
being opened up.
And more interestingly,
it's being
opened up technologically.
And it seems like when things
get opened up technologically,
we're less afraid of them.
Michael Persinger
creates the God Helmet.
He basically puts in on, it
shoots electromagnetic fields
into your right temporal lobe.
We know right temporal
lobe epilepsy,
when this part of the
brain gets excited,
we have out-of-body experiences.
We have near-death experiences.
By the way, the same
part of your brain
gets very excited in dreaming.
So we have this
experience every night.
But we can now stimulate
this with technology.
Doesn't work all the time.
Doesn't work for everybody.
But we're getting
better and better at it.
And people are-- we might be
hesitant about taking a drug,
or we write it off.
But if it's
technologically mediated,
we're a lot more
comfortable with it.
JASON SILVA: A lot
more open to it.
STEVEN KOTLER: It's
allowing us to open up
this really crazy space that
we don't really understand.
JASON SILVA: Yeah.
Well, I mean, it
captures my imagination,
especially when you
say north of happiness.
Because I mean, what is
the self-help movement,
the happiness movement,
billion-dollar industries.
People trying to figure out
new metrics for happiness
because it turns out that
getting everything you want
is not going to make you happy.
And that experiences,
for example,
are more valuable
than things when
it comes to longer-form
satisfaction and satiation.
But we are an
existential species.
We are an agitated species.
With our minds, we can
ponder the infinite.
Now I'm channeling
Ernest Becker.
We can ponder the
infinite, yet we're
housed in heart pumping, breath
gasping, decaying bodies.
So our greatest
ecstasies are haunted,
are shadowed by the fact
that they are temporary,
that we are finite-- no
matter how many times we get
the goosebumps and
are moved to tears
by beautiful art, or beautiful
ecstasy, or beautiful rhapsody.
So my question for
you-- when you're
talking about
north of happiness,
technological
mediation, I'm reminded
of David Pearce's work,
"The Hedonistic Imperative."
Are you familiar
with David Pearce?
He's a transhumanist
philosopher that
believes that we are going
to institute a paradise
engineering, as
he calls it, where
we're going to be using
new biotechnologies
and nanotechnologies to
shift our hedonic treadmill
and to literally
neuroengineer gradients
of bliss that will make even our
greatest ecstasies today pale.
He calls them our Darwinian,
old-school ecstasies
compared to what
we're going to create.
Where do you stand on
that idea, not just
in terms of the science, but
in terms of the poet in you?
Does this excite you, this
idea of creating spaces
so much more north of happy, and
what that's going to be like?
STEVEN KOTLER: So we have
something called an hedonic set
point.
An hedonic set point
basically means
that somewhere between ages six
and 12, the amount of happiness
and sadness you're going to
feel in life is pretty much set.
It's why you feel the same
emotionally at 10, at 20,
at 30, at 40.
It's roughly the same
bandwidth of emotion.
It's because we have these
things called emotional set
points.
And they get locked down.
I'm less interested
in the super-ecstatic.
I just think it's interesting.
But it's very bizarre.
And I have no idea
what comes from that.
But what happens if we
can just shift everybody
and we're 3% happier?
And that's really,
really possible.
For example, we know--
mass amounts of research
back this up--
that the people who
have the most flow in
their lives, it's often
said that people with the
most flow in their lives
are the happiest
people on Earth.
And it's actually a misnomer.
Happiness is a
temporary condition.
People with the most
flow in their lives
score off the charts
on life satisfaction
and well being tests.
So it's meaning and it's
overall possibility.
JASON SILVA: Beyond happiness.
STEVEN KOTLER: Right,
it's beyond happiness.
So we know flow, repeated
exposure to flow,
can shift your
emotional set point.
It's one of the only things
that can actually shift this.
So that's where it starts
to get interesting.
Because we know
this is possible.
We know this is doable.
So what happens if we move an
entire society a couple degrees
up that ladder?
That's interesting to me.
JASON SILVA: That's
a happy place to be.
STEVEN KOTLER: Well, it
means a whole lot less fear.
So that first filter we were
talking about gets damped down.
And then the possibility
space gets really interesting.
JASON SILVA: Wow.
That gets me very happy, bro.
STEVEN KOTLER: I'm so glad.
JASON SILVA: So can we talk
a little bit about your work?
People say that people who
live in their flow state
kind of build their
whole lives around it.
You live in a dog
sanctuary that you
created, which I think is one
of the most amazing things ever.
Because you're this amazingly
gifted writer, writing
all these New York
bestsellers, but you
live with all these dogs.
Can you tell me a little bit
about what you discovered
about animals, and how that
gets you into your flow state,
a little bit?
STEVEN KOTLER: Well,
a couple of things.
JASON SILVA: I'm in awe of
that aspect of your life.
STEVEN KOTLER: I run a animal
sanctuary called Rancho de
Chihuahua.
And we deal with hospice
care and special needs care
for really sick small dogs.
And really, really sick.
Most of our animals
show up to us,
they come directly
from vets often,
with a month to live, two months
to live, that kind of thing.
Flow is at the heart of
our healing methodology.
And as I said earlier, it
boosts the immune system.
It resets the
[INAUDIBLE] system.
Our animals live for
a really long time.
So we actually do put these--
we were talking about,
is flow trainable?
We put our dogs in
the flow all the time.
It's actually not hard.
By the way, we don't know
if it's all animals that
are hard-wired for flow.
We know it's dogs.
And we know at some point
down the mammalian chain,
it probably cuts off.
And we don't know where.
But we absolutely know
dogs can get into flow.
What else do you want
me to talk about?
JASON SILVA: No, no.
I just wanted you
to talk about that.
But I also want to bring
up the subject, just
because usually when
I'm in a flow state,
I'm usually very quickly
marveling at something,
because I'm a very
curious person.
So I'm always like, I want
to get into a flow state
and see a movie.
I want to get into
a flow state and go
for a walk in some
beautiful spot,
maybe like Big Sur or whatever.
And there was this great book
by Allison Griffiths called
"Shivers Down Your Spine."
It talked about cinema,
Gothic cathedrals,
and the immersive view.
And so she was talking
about external technologies
that we use to trigger
these states of rapture,
states of awe.
And she said Gothic cathedrals
are designed in a certain way
to put you in touch with the
sublime, to hack your brain,
and put you in awe right away.
The modern incarnation of
that, the IMAX Theater.
She says you go into an IMAX
Theater, and right off the bat,
the space is already doing
something to your perception.
It's already doing
something to your mood.
And there's been a
lot of recent science
about this emotion of awe.
That it turns out that
experiences that stretch
your perceptual boundaries
force you to create
new maps of the world.
And in assimilating
these new experiences,
you experience this
cognitive ecstasy, this awe.
And after the moment
passes, you're
left with increased
feelings, residual feelings,
of heightened creativity,
heightened well being,
heightened satisfaction--
which is already wonderful.
And additionally, these
experiences of awe
are anti-inflammatory.
So they're also good for you.
So what is your take on
this side emotion of awe
and where it fits in with flow?
STEVEN KOTLER: Yeah.
What we know about
awe, actually,
is-- so one of the triggers
for flow, one of the things
that will drive us into
flow is what's technically
called a rich environment.
Which is a fancy way of
saying lots of novelty,
lots of complexity, lots
of unpredictability.
Complexity is what triggers awe.
So when you stare
up at the night sky,
and you see a billion galaxies,
and you cannot process it,
your conscious mind
literally cannot process it.
So what happens in flow is
we trade conscious processing
for subconscious processing.
Flow is the only
time we actually
get to watch the
subconscious mind work.
And the reason it's
such a weird state,
conscious thought travels
about 150 miles an hour.
Subconscious thought, 2,000
to 5,000 miles an hour.
So it's hyperspeed
decision making.
Awe is the front
edge of a flow state.
So when you look up
at the night sky,
and you get sucked
in, and time dilation,
everything freezes for a minute.
That's actually the front
end of the flow state.
And so we know from-- this
is Teresa Amabile's work
at Harvard.
She figured out that the height
in creativity that shows up
in flow actually outlasts
the flow state by a day,
by two days.
It suggests-- and this
is really incredible.
One thing we know-- and the best
example of this is something
called the Red Bull
Creativity Project.
Red Bull, the energy
drink company,
teamed up with MIT and TED.
And they did the largest
study of creativity ever done.
They looked at everything.
They learned two things.
One, creativity is fundamental
to society-- big surprise.
Two, we can't teach anybody
how to more creative.
We suck at it.
So what Teresa Amabile
discovered at Harvard
is flow actually
trains the brain up
to be more creative
over the long haul.
It extends for a couple of days.
What we're seeing in
awe is it extending
for a couple of hours.
It's a small-scale
flow state, basically.
JASON SILVA: Wonderful.
Well, we've got
five more minutes
for the official talk portion.
And then we'd love to open it
up to questions from you guys.
So if you want to start
thinking about some questions.
Do you have a question?
STEVEN KOTLER: I want to
actually turn the question
you asked me back on you.
Which is-- because you've
been thinking about this a lot
and talking about this a lot.
But what do you
think this means?
If we can start
producing these states,
if we can start opening up
this so-called ecstatic space--
and by the way, if we
use the word "ecstasy,"
I'm not talking
about the club drug.
I'm talking about-- the Greek
root for ecstasy is "ekstasis."
It means to get
out of your head.
And just--
JASON SILVA: Be
beside ourselves.
STEVEN KOTLER: To
be beside ourselves.
And by the way, we
did a research study
at the Flow Genome Project.
We wanted to see how
much money people spend
getting out of their head.
So we basically added
up all the things
people do to get
out of their heads.
And we did it in the most
conservative possible way
we could have done the math.
It's $10 trillion a year.
One sixth of the
global economy is
what we spend getting
out of our heads,
and getting out of ourselves.
That's what we spend.
JASON SILVA: The
altered states economy.
STEVEN KOTLER: The altered
states economy, exactly.
It's one sixth of
the global economy.
JASON SILVA: Yeah, which
I think is wonderful.
Because when we get
out of our heads, not
to bring up psychedelic
language, but
we dissolve boundaries.
We dissolve
boundaries of thought.
We dissolve patterns
in our thinking.
We see the world in a new way.
We get something akin to the
astronaut overview effect.
We see the gestalt
from a different angle.
So I feel like it makes
us less rigid people,
more compassionate people,
more tolerant people.
Only good comes from getting
out of our heads, I find.
I find it to be a
wonderfully romantic release
to get rid of yourself
for a little while,
and to find that there's
something there afterwards.
STEVEN KOTLER: I
think the only problem
with it is it's
massively addictive.
You can pretty easily
go down the rabbit hole
of I want my brain to be
turned off all the time
and you don't come back.
JASON SILVA: But what
about taking lessons
from that other space and
then having integration?
There's a lot of stuff
in the literature
now, in the science,
in the news,
about psychedelic
psychotherapy--
so giving PTSD
patients some MDMA
and compressing 10 years
of normal psychotherapy
into six hours.
The kind of
ontological shift that
can be triggered by these
technologies of inner space
and what that can lead us to.
Michael Pollan's article
in "The New Yorker"
recently was saying,
maybe what we
can do is not just
talk about how
we can help people
that are pathologically
suffering from PTSD.
But what about
taking those insights
and applying them for
people that are OK,
so making well people better.
Could we use
psychedelic therapies
for people that would identify
as not being traumatized.
STEVEN KOTLER: If
you go back to-- I
don't know what you guys know
about psychedelic research.
But before Nixon shut it all
down, thousands of studies
were done.
And most of them-- a lot of
them were done on addiction.
Psychedelics turn out
to be very, very good
for fighting addiction.
But they're also, most of
them were done on creativity.
Which is why Steve
Jobs said, LSD
is one of the three great
things I've done in my life.
I think you have to be
fairly repressed for LSD
to be that great of
an experience for you,
but OK, whatever.
It's Steve Jobs for you.
He was.
But it definitely opens up a
whole new level of possibility.
If you go back-- you mentioned
the PTSD MDMA studies.
If you guys actually
look at those studies,
they're astounding.
They looked at war veterans--
Iraq and Afghanistan-- people
with really serious PTSD.
And they looked at sexual
trauma victims and child abuse
victims.
And they were finding that they
could overwrite the PTSD in one
to two sessions.
So 20 years of
therapy doesn't work.
All the drugs we've got
on the market don't work.
But two MDMA sessions
seem to work really fast.
JASON SILVA: There you go.
No surprise there, actually.
Cool, guys.
Well, we'd love to turn it over
to some questions from you.
This has been really fun.
But I feel like you guys could
probably catalyze some offshoot
conversation.
WOMAN 1: Two questions.
The first was when you
were talking about flow,
and you said, we have this
interesting opportunity
to study extreme sports.
And the ones that
are really flowing
are the ones that
are successful.
And yet, the ones that aren't
flowing go to the hospital
or die.
But you said when
you're in flow,
you can have higher risk taking.
So is it possible they're in
flow, but they just are risky,
and therefore they
have an accident?
STEVEN KOTLER:
Certainly you have that.
Scot Schmidt, who was one
of the early extreme skiers,
said flow makes you
feel like Superman up
until the moment you're not.
Which is very, very true.
And certainly in
the shit happens
category, stuff happens.
You can be in a flow state.
You can be flying down the
hill on a mountain bike
and hit a rock.
And you put yourself
in the hospital.
I broke 84 bones
that way, literally.
So yes, there is some of that.
And risk-taking definitely
goes [INAUDIBLE].
There's a study that
just actually came out
of Germany that showed that
people, every time-- risk
is one of the things
that focus attention.
It drives you into flow.
It's a really
great flow trigger.
And it also drives
dopamine in the brain,
which is a focusing chemical,
among everything else it does.
So all this stuff is really
great to drive you into flow.
But over your lifetime,
absolutely you
will take greater
and greater risks,
and greater and greater risks,
and greater and greater risks.
So that will definitely happen.
Usually what happens
with the younger action
sport athletes is they
have Kodak courage.
They're getting by on youth,
and balls, and adrenalin.
And it will only get you so far.
Usually what happens
with flow, because it's
a much calmer space, people
tend to make better decisions
as a general rule.
You obviously can still kill
yourself in flow states.
But as a general rule,
people make better decisions.
JASON SILVA: So it would
be a better-informed risk
if you were to take the risk.
STEVEN KOTLER: It's a
better informed risk, yeah.
WOMAN 1: My second
question was, I just
spent the weekend in an
art of dying conference.
And they do use
psilocybin to ease anxiety
at the end of life.
So in terms of the flow, or
training people with flow,
do you think that it would
limit the fear of death?
And also, is it possible to
be in the flow in later years?
I mean, obviously you
can die at any age.
But is there any--
STEVEN KOTLER: There's no age.
So what we know about
flow is it's ubiquitous.
It shows up in anyone,
anywhere, provided
certain initial
conditions are met.
So there's no age limits
on flow whatsoever.
We also know-- so
what psilocybin
does is it creates a sense
of oneness with everything.
Where that sense
comes from, actually,
is transient hypofrontality.
So there's a part of your
brain, the right parietal lobe,
that is what separate--
generates a barrier
between self and others.
So it exists so I can
walk around this room
and not bump into furniture.
So if I have a stroke
or brain damage
to this part of my
brain, I can't sit down
on a couch, because I don't
know where my leg ends
and the couch begins.
So during intense
concentration--
like shows up in
meditation, or flow,
or things like this-- part
of the brain shuts down.
And we can no longer
separate self from other.
And that point,
you're convinced--
because there's no
other data available--
that you are one
with everything.
The same thing is going on if
you're using psilocybin or LSD.
It's the same mechanism.
All the roads lead to Rome.
It doesn't matter
how you get in.
So in terms of using flow to
combat end-of-life anxiety?
Absolutely.
Absolutely, it would
work very, very well.
It might be interesting
to couple it
with psilocybin or some
of those other therapies.
WOMAN 1: Right.
Because the people that are
doing the research in this,
it's not like the psilocybin
is giving you anything.
What it is, it's activating
what you already are capable of.
JASON SILVA: Well, I
think what Rich Doyle says
is that psychedelics, they don't
really have an effect per se.
But they're nonspecific
amplifiers of consciousness.
So what really sculpts
the psychedelic trip
is your set and your setting.
So the setting is
the place that you've
pre-configured, that
you've architected,
where the trip is
going to unfold.
And of course, the
set is what you're
bringing to that--
your predispositions,
your fears, your
anxieties, your intention,
what you want to resolve, what
you want to probe and explore.
And what you come to
perceive in those moments,
according to the work of
Rich Doyle, who I adore,
is that you come
to perceive, first
of all, the feedback
loops between
your creative and linguistic
choices and your consciousness.
In other words, once
the trip starts,
you realize just how
much where you are
is determining your
subjective experience.
If you're in a mystical,
beautiful park in Big Sur,
you start to feel mystical,
beautiful sensations.
But you're feeling those
already unconsciously just
by being there.
But the trip, in amplifying
and bringing forth
that subconscious feeling,
all of a sudden the theater
of the moment is informed
by the stage that you're in.
So if you're in that
beautiful place,
it's already coloring the
trip towards beautiful spaces.
If you pre-configure
music-- there's
an article by
Timothy Leary written
in the '60s called "Programming
the Psychedelic Experience."
Which was all about the idea
that if you could successfully
pattern and pre-configure
the input signals that
were coming in when a
person is in a highly
suggestible psychedelic state,
you could script the journey.
You could literally
outline and steer
awareness and subjectivity.
So you could create your own
compressed version of a Joseph
Campbell hero's journey.
You could take the psilocybin,
depart from the ordinary,
go down the rabbit hole, learn
new things about yourself,
see the world in a new way,
have cathartic realizations,
and make the return.
And holy moly, talk about
compressing a journey
into a journey.
But I think this is
really fascinating.
You can tell I'm very
passionate about this.
STEVEN KOTLER: Jason Silva,
ladies and gentlemen.
JASON SILVA: No, no.
But there's a lot to do here.
But really, the key idea
is that consciousness
is a collaborative act
between subject and object.
And it becomes even more
so a collaborative act
between subject and object when
you are in a psychedelically
addled state.
You realize that
mind, that awareness,
is a co-production
between self and world.
It's all about
these feedback loops
that you just come to
witness and you come to see.
So that can either be
a frightening bummer
if you're in the
wrong set and setting,
or can be nirvana in the
right set and setting.
STEVEN KOTLER: What Jason said.
I don't know how to follow that.
JASON SILVA: OK, we've
got a couple more minutes.
Any?
Yes.
WOMAN 2: So is there any way
that those really negative
feelings that you associate
with the frontal lobe
can actually stimulate
a state of flow?
Because I had a moment of
terrible fear and anxiety,
like crippling, and I gave
the best talk of my life.
STEVEN KOTLER: Oh, yeah.
WOMAN 2: And then the next
week, I was really meditative.
And I gave a really boring talk.
STEVEN KOTLER: Oh, yeah.
So I said earlier,
there's a flow cycle.
The first part of the
cycle is known as struggle.
And it is-- your prefrontal
cortex may go away in flow.
This is all prefrontal cortex.
Struggle is called
struggle for a reason.
It is really unpleasant.
It is a learning phase.
It is a loading phase.
You are loading and overloading
the brain with information.
I often found when I was a-- I
made my living as a journalist
for 20, 25 years.
And I always found
the best stories,
I wanted a flow
state experience.
But I would find that
I had to be really--
the trip had to scare me.
The journey had to scare me.
That night before,
I wasn't sleeping
for weeks, because I was
going off to the Himalayas
to go chase whatever.
I would really work myself
into a state, a really negative
state, so that even a little
bit of a positive experience
could kick me into flow.
It didn't take
much at that point,
because I had freaked myself
out so much ahead of time.
So yeah.
Both Jason and myself will tell
you we're both flow junkies.
And we're both totally neurotic.
And a lot of the reason
I think I got into this
is because it's bad up here.
I've got to do a lot
to get out of here
under normal conditions.
JASON SILVA: I agree.
Very neurotic.
And not only that,
but I'm obsessed
with Ernest Becker, who wrote
the book "The Denial of Death,"
because I'm extremely haunted
by the idea of transience
and mortality.
And I can vouch for the fact
that when I'm in a flow state,
it's the only time
when bliss rules.
There's no thoughts
about, oh, this
is all going to end one day.
So why even be excited, because
it's all temporary, anyway.
And everything
dissolves into nothing.
But when I'm in a
flow state, and I'm
watching an amazing movie or I'm
listening to beautiful music,
or I'm being blown
away by the ideas
that somebody's
sharing-- holy shit.
I'm in the eternal now.
And death doesn't exist.
MAN 1: Yeah.
I'm curious.
How are these flow states--
you talk about extreme sports.
I've been a surfer for 30 years.
In the last 10 years, the
shit that's been happening,
you can't even believe it.
And is it epigenetics
through YouTube?
Or is it-- people are getting
into these flow states.
And you see somebody
do something.
It's like that
Laird Hamilton photo
that came on "Surfer" magazine.
I mean, literally, just
everyone was, what the hell?
And five years later,
everybody's doing it.
And I see it over
and over again.
And it just fascinates me.
STEVEN KOTLER: That was one
of the-- one of the reasons
that I got interested
in this field is
from for my early
career as a journalist,
I chased action sport
athletes around mountains
for five, six years.
And obviously, I'm not
an action sport athlete.
So I broke a lot of
bones along the way.
And I would have these
year-long injuries,
where I'd have 65 hairline
fractures in my leg
and I didn't move for a year.
And I would come back to
the sport a year later.
And it was like 30 years
of evolution in a year.
And my first question was,
what the hell's going on?
How is this even possible?
So what actually happened in
action sports, a lot of it
was-- so creativity
is a flow trigger.
Creativity is amplified by flow.
But the actual
pattern recognition
when you link
ideas together, you
get a tiny squirt of dopamine.
We've all had this experience.
You've done a crossword puzzle.
You get an answer right.
That little rush of
pleasure you get afterwards,
that's dopamine.
Dopamine also tunes
signal-to-noise ratios,
meaning it allows us
to see more patterns.
So the reason you get one
crossword answer right,
and then you get a
couple in a row right,
it's because dopamine is
helping you see more patterns.
Creativity-- and it happened
because of snowboarding.
Snowboarding was a banned sport.
So people started
hiking their snowboards
to the top of the mountains.
If you're hiking your snowboard
to the top of a mountain,
you don't want to be the
fastest person to the bottom,
because you just spent four
hours getting to the top.
And that's stupid.
So instead, it became the
most creative way down
is the winner.
And there's not just one winner.
Everybody can win.
So this was adopted.
It was free riding
in snowboarding.
It became free skiing,
and free surfing,
and on, and on, and on.
And it became about creativity.
And that in combination with
the risk and the other factors
just started driving
so much flow.
But the other thing
that happened, in 1986
we invented the VCR.
And it sounds really funny.
But try to learn a
dynamic action sports move
from a static magazine photo.
It sucks.
It's really hard to do.
But with the
invention of the VCR,
by 1986, I think it was
50% of American homes had
a VCR in it by that point.
And suddenly, especially
for skaters, they
were the first to notice it.
You could pause and rewind.
And it became this
training manual.
So technology,
coupled with flow,
created this massive
feedback loop that
led us to where we are today.
MAN 1: Yeah.
I'm old enough to grow
up with the magazines.
And I had a pivotal
moment where I
was trying to learn how
to do an off the lip when
I was young and [INAUDIBLE]
top of the wave.
And I saw so many pictures.
And I would hit,
and I would stop.
And a friend said, you're
stopping with the picture
as it flows--
STEVEN KOTLER: That's awesome.
MAN 1: And I was
like, [INAUDIBLE].
STEVEN KOTLER:
That's pretty funny.
MAN 1: And then five
years later, everybody's
learning it through
the whole motion
that we didn't have back then.
STEVEN KOTLER: That's funny.
Yeah, I was talking
to Ian Walsh,
who's another great surfer.
And he was talking about this.
And he says, by the
time he goes home--
he lives 10 minutes from Jaws.
But by the time
he's home from Jaws,
somebody has uploaded the
footage of his session
onto YouTube.
And he can start doing
video playback review
as soon as he gets home because
of where the technology is.
JASON SILVA: Any
other questions?
Yeah.
MAN 2: Are either of
you, during this talk,
were either of you
in a flow state?
And if so, how'd you get there?
And if not, why not?
JASON SILVA: Interesting.
We both do a lot of
speaking all the time.
And I was talking to
him about this earlier.
Sometimes the
focusing that happens
when you are in
front of people--
which means I don't feel
entitled to people's time
at all.
So my brain, right off the
bat, is getting really focused
and making sure that
whatever it's doing up here
is going to be
useful information.
There's not a lot
of "ums" or "buts"
or taking my time when I talk.
Because I don't feel
entitled to your time.
So I get really focused.
And then there's that space
where knowledge and skill
set meets opportunity.
It's not easy, but it's not too
hard, that I get overwhelmed.
It's just enough that I'm in a
happy place, where I'm really
focused, but I can handle this.
And yes, there are moments
when I go into deep flow.
What about you?
STEVEN KOTLER: Sometimes.
But interestingly, when we
train people up in flow,
obviously, risk is important.
I talk a lot about
action sport athletes.
And everybody's
always like, oh, but I
don't want to take physical
risks to get into flow.
That sucks.
I don't want to break
bones and whatever.
And I say well, great news.
You don't need physical risk.
You can replace it
with emotional risk,
intellectual risk,
or social risk.
And the cool thing
is social risk,
your brain can't
tell the difference
between physical danger
and social danger.
They're processed in the
exact same structures.
Which is why fear
of public speaking
is the number one
fear in the world,
and not, say, getting
eaten by a grizzly bear.
You would think from an
evolutionary perspective,
getting eaten by a grizzly
bear is something scary.
But no, it's public speaking.
And the reason is if
you go back 300 years,
and you screwed up socially,
you get kicked out.
Kicked out of the tribe.
Exiled.
Banished.
Capital punishment.
So the brain can't tell the
difference between social fear
and physical fear.
So being on stage-- even if
you do it a lot-- it definitely
focuses you a lot.
And I think Jason's right.
I don't feel entitled
anybody's time.
So I don't want
to bore you guys.
So that helps drive
attention, as well.
In the back.
WOMAN 3: Hi.
You mentioned, Jason,
the eternal now,
which is a term that's
obviously connected sometimes
to spirituality and mysticism.
And I think you touch
on that lightly.
Can you guys talk
a little bit more
about any correlations with
spirituality and mysticism,
if at all in your research
with the states of flow?
JASON SILVA: Oh,
he definitely can.
You know about the neurobiology
of mystical experience.
It's a chapter in
your new book, right?
STEVEN KOTLER: Yeah.
There's a chapter in
"Tomorrowland" on it.
So earlier when I was talking
about knobs and levers
in the brain-- I'm not saying
that there's no mystery.
And I personally am an atheist.
But just because
I can tell you how
the neurobiology of
spiritual experience works,
all that means is
these experiences
are mediated in the brain.
So if you're spiritually
inclined, if you're religious,
what I'm talking about does
not disavow what you believe.
It just says these experiences
are mediated through the brain.
But we now know
that flow states,
so-called mystical experiences,
psychedelic-- these
are all the same
structures in the brain.
And we're getting really good
at figuring out where they are,
and how to precipitate them.
Where I think that's
interesting is
I think we're at the
very front edge of this.
I think for years,
and years, and years,
if you go by what the Buddhist
meditators have told us,
that these things go
on and on forever.
There's layer, after
layer, after layer.
I think we're at the front
edge of decoding that stuff.
I'm really interested
to what happens
as we get deeper and deeper.
Because there are weird
questions, even in flow.
We were talking
about this earlier.
You have access to really
high-quality information.
90% of it makes sense.
90% of it, you're like, OK,
I get where this comes from.
10% of it doesn't make
any sense whatsoever.
And it really feels magical.
And there's not an easy
way to explain it away.
I'd certainly love an
explanation for it.
And I think poking
deeper into these realms,
especially into the
science of these realms,
is going to get us there.
But open questions.
JASON SILVA: I think this
will be our last question,
and then we'll just
do a little chit chat.
But yep?
WOMAN 4: You had talked about 17
ways to get into a flow state.
Risk has been like--
STEVEN KOTLER: OK, so if
you go to stevenkotler.com--
K-O-T-L-E-R is how you
spell my last name--
if you type in your email,
you'll get a free PDF for flow
in performance.
And it breaks down all
17 of those triggers,
and a little bit
of the flow cycle,
and tell you how to apply them.
But you can finish
asking your question.
WOMAN 4: You had focused
primarily on risk, and action
sports, and so forth.
So I'm just wondering what are
the other really important ones
that you would argue.
JASON SILVA: I would say
one of them is cannabis.
STEVEN KOTLER: That's
not on the list.
JASON SILVA: And
especially now the ubiquity
of medical marijuana,
turning points.
There's actually a
lot of literature
I found online about
weed and flow states.
Certainly Carl Sagan,
I think, would agree.
A lot of jazz
musicians would agree.
STEVEN KOTLER: He's not wrong.
If you want the cheapest
flow hack in the world--
20-minute run, cup of coffee,
marijuana, that order.
It's the exact same
neurochemical cocktail as flow.
Simple.
But I'll go with the classic.
MAN 3: The other?
STEVEN KOTLER: No.
You need-- you want to
exercise to the point
that the voice in
your head is gone.
And that's it.
So go for a long walk.
And when the voice
in your head sorta
quiets down, drink
a cup of coffee,
smoke a joint-- that order.
There you go.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON SILVA: It's the truth.
STEVEN KOTLER: It is the truth.
But to answer your question,
the most famous of all flows
triggers is what's known as
the challenge skills balance.
So the idea here-- and you
alluded to it a second ago-- is
we pay most attention-- so
every one of these flow triggers
are literally just ways of
driving attention into the now.
Flow follows focus.
So all these triggers
are-- basically
the 17 triggers that we know
of-- they're the 17 things
evolution shaped your brain
to pay the most attention to.
So one of them is called the
challenge skills balance.
It means I pay the most
attention to the task at hand
when the task at hand makes
me stretch but not snap.
So you want something
that's difficult.
It's beyond your
skill set but not
too difficult that it's
starting to generate
massive amounts of fear.
It's a tricky balance to find.
For example, under-performers
don't like it
because you hit this
sweet spot, it's
usually the point you start
to get really uncomfortable.
There's no way around it.
You're beyond your
comfort zone, literally.
But for overachievers,
they screw up
because overachievers-- so a guy
named Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi
is often called the godfather
of flow-- he's a University
of Chicago psychologist-- and
a Google mathematician sat
down and tried to
figure out what
is the exact
challenge-skills ratio.
And the number, the gradient
difference they came up with,
back of the envelope
calculation--
this is not a real number.
This is not real science.
It's pretend science.
But the number was 4%.
So a 4% difference between
challenge and skills.
What happens with really high
performers is we'll blow by 4%
without even noticing.
We'll take on challenge that's
10% greater, 20% greater,
30% greater.
Generates so much fear,
you will block yourself
from a flow state.
So we pay the most
attention to those things
where we stretch but don't snap.
They call it the flow channel.
What it basically means that
there's not enough stimulation,
you're bored.
You're not paying a
whole lot of attention.
Too much stimulation,
there's anxiety,
and it'll kick you out.
In between is this sweet
spot, this flow channel.
And that can be applied
anywhere, obviously-- sports,
creativity, writing, whatever.
In my writing, I always
know I'm going to write.
So I tend to believe
that, for me at least,
other people will
argue with me, I guess.
But for me, the best writing
is just really honest.
I want to tell the truth, tell
the truth, tell the truth.
I always know that
I'm in that sweet spot
when I'm a little nervous
to publish something
because I've been a
little too vulnerable.
That's how I know that I've
been in that sweet spot
while I was writing.
Does that help?
WOMAN 4: Mhm.
JASON SILVA: Beautiful.
Well, I think we're going to
end the formal discussion.
But we're going to mingle
here for a little while.
And yeah.
Thank you so much, guys.
STEVEN KOTLER: Thank you, guys.
JAMIE WHEAL: And you take
just take physical fitness out
of the beach muscles,
cosmetic and aesthetic.
And you turn it into
athletic and neurokinetic.
So you've just completely just
rebooted physical culture.
And actually, it's more of
a throwback to 19th century
Germany and the
gymnasium effects, which
is a throwback to Plato,
and the original Academy,
and Pythagoras.
[MUSIC PLAYING]